So we have seen that using the ROB
and something like the Tomasulo algorithm, we can enforce
the order of dependencies on registers between instructions.
The question still remains what about memory access ordering?
We have a lot of store instructions. Do
they really need to be done strictly in program
order, or can we do something about reordering
them too? So far, we have eliminated control dependencies,
using branch prediction, and eliminated false dependencies
on registers, that is dependencies that go through
registers, and we have eliminated the false dependencies
through register renaming. Next, we learn how to
obey read after write register dependencies or
through dependencies. And we do that through Tamasulo-like
scheduling. So we have instructions wait in reservation
stations until their dependencies have been satisfied and
they can proceed to execution out of program
order. Note that the data dependence handling that
we have done so for, however, is only
for register dependencies. That is when one instruction
is producing a value in a register that
another is going to be using. But what about
memory dependencies? If we have a store and
then a load, there could also be a dependence
between the memory value written by the store and
then the value read by the load. If these two
addresses are the same address then actually the load
needs to get the value from the store and in
which case we should be doing them in order.
However, if these two addresses are not the same, just
like with registers, we actually don't need to maintain the
program order between this accesses. However, we have not seen
anything that handle out of order execution of memory instruction.